all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are covering Wolverine versus
Predator and as far as I'm aware this is
the first time that Marvel's ever
published a story like this so much like
all the other stories that have ever
existed in the history of comic books
where it's like alien versus whoever or
Predator versus whoever it's just the
kind of General assumption that people
are aware of their existence they've
always kind of been there
um we're just now seeing a story where
they encounter someone so what this does
here because honestly you guys care
about the fight and you guys don't care
about the setup there's a few things
that go on here first and foremost the
Predator does arrive on earth right and
when it shows up here it does what most
Predators would do when they get to a
new planet they start going after the
indigenous life now it's not to like
destroy them right or at least eradicate
all life is to really just kind of
figure out what the hierarchy is right
like starting with the first thing it
attacks and going from there so the
first thing it does is it kills like an
elk right or a deer or whatever this
thing happens to me I can never tell the
difference between be honest with you
but then after that that it goes after
like a mountain lion it goes after a
mountain goat it goes after an orca
right just these different things that
seem to have different levels of
strength or durability and a lot of it
is just based on observation right
that's really all it is and then it
notices often the distance there is
smoke emanating from a local village now
at that point we switch over to
Wolverine now this takes place and one
of the things to know with the
miniseries this is four issues long it's
going to span four months and each issue
will take place at different points in
Wolverine's life this one takes place in
the very early days right after he had
like popped his claws and his
traditional origin and then taken off to
the Northwest Territories to live up
there in Northern Canada and especially
up in Alaska right so by and large he's
removed from most of society but he's
still pretty young so he does not have
adamantium claws yet right it's just
bone but he ends up coming across a guy
named Tucker and Tucker is basically
like a prospector right who made himself
Rich out there and then some rival
faction and ended up kidnapping a son
and so on and so forth so he basically
hires Wolverine to like track these guys
down and try to kill him the issue is
that once they get to where these guys
are supposed to be they find them all
hung upside down and skinned which again
is normal when you're dealing with a
predator right it's like one of the
Hallmarks of predators entirely and it
even takes Tucker by surprise right he's
kind of like what in the heck but then
they end up coming across a house and
that's where these guys are supposed to
be laying low now while this happens the
Predator sees Wolverine and then stands
back and watches because Wolverine even
in these early days just had an extreme
level of ferocity right the Berserker
rage hadn't quite become a core part of
his character but he was getting there
but having that level of ferocity the
Predators just kind of like okay this is
dope this guy might be a challenge
Wolverine goes in there and Slaughters
everyone right and then in turn he's
shot in the back by Tucker come to find
out the whole story about his son was
was a lie that these guys were all
people that were working with Tucker in
like a railroad Heist then they turned
on and they took the money for
themselves so he hired Wolverine to kill
these guys so he could take the money
for himself he goes to leave and then he
gets his head blown off by the Predator
which is amazing
it's absolutely awesome and then the
predator of course as we know from just
their experience on any indigenous World
specifically Earth they overhear things
and they kind of start learning in the
process so it starts talking right like
they're Killers they're monsters just
kind of repeating the phrase over and
over again and then the fight breaks out
between himself and Wolverine and this
thing is intense right it is amazing
right Wolverine literally like rips This
Guy's mask off or really just kind of
slashes his throat then he pulls his
mask off and then Wolverine's like
whatever you are I'm gonna carve the
ugly off of you right and the fight is
pretty hardcore and in fact when
Wolverine goes to attack this thing it
cuts his claws off right on one of his
hands Cuts him right off right so
Wolverine starts to realize just how big
of a threat this guy is in turn it
impales him right stabs Wolverine
through the chest and then Wolverine
having gotten the slash on him it's kind
of the opening Salvo right in a lot of
ways it's just one testing the other to
see what they're capable of Wolverine of
course just takes off running with this
spear stuck in his body pulls the thing
out and then his healing Factor starts
to kick in and it's really really cool
right the narration is like we were both
cut deep and we both had our own ways of
healing of course Wolverine has this
healing Factor the Predator has
technology and so what's awesome is like
they're both healing and recovering
because eventually the Predator catches
up to Wolverine now one of the funny
things he says he says I was young but
I'd seen more than my share of blood and
trouble this thing though was on another
level I wasn't one to run from a fight
but I knew if I was going to win this
one I needed to move fast and think
smart or I'd be just another bloody or
tournament hung from a tree and so even
when he's trying to get away it's not
one of those where he's like running out
of fear it's a Sun Tzu Art of War type
thing when encountering an enemy fight
them on the terrain that's most familiar
to you so even when the smart disc is
thrown and it like stabs Wolverine in
the leg he's able to get away and get
back to his cave only for the Predator
to jump in the way and try to block him
from getting out of this thing now when
that happens this bear immediately comes
out of the cave and attacks the Predator
now here's what's so cool about this
when Wolverine was out there in the wild
honestly he made friends with animals
more than he made friends with people
because he didn't like people right
that's just one of the core elements of
his character in the early days he
didn't like Humanity it was really not a
fear or anything it was really more just
more of like a distaste right exhaustion
frustration things like that he saw
human beings as being more trouble than
their work so he was basically everybody
in their 30s going forward in the modern
era but the thing about this is that
when he was making friends he actually
kind of had like a bear as not really a
pet but more of like a companion and the
bear attacks and this is when Wolverine
doesn't fully understand what he's
dealing with a bear is a formidable foe
but the Predators are ridiculously dense
right just in terms of their body
structure they're incredibly capable so
this is Wolverine underestimating what
he's facing off against because in this
moment instead of like following in with
the bear and killing the Predator he
celebrates the moment right he
celebrates what's going on here and in
turn he of course pulls the smart disc
out of his leg and then just kind of
continues on then he just sort of walks
away but he has this really amazing
monologue right he says I thought that
was the end there was always some new
danger waiting for me so I soon turned
my attention to it it's easy to forget
pain when your wounds heal like dried up
creaks what I didn't realize not until
many years later was that this was just
the beginning of what turned out to be
the longest hunt of both of our
miserable lives because what it does is
it time skips it jumps forward to South
America and it picks up with Professor
Thornton and team X now for those of you
guys who don't know anything about team
X and about Wolverine's history it's one
of the coolest things so a little bit of
History here before Wolverine became
Wolverine which is to say having the
adamantium bonded to his skeleton and
all that kind of stuff he was part of a
wet work team that worked with the CIA
and the idea behind this is they were
like sent out on all kinds of missions I
mean these guys toppled governments they
killed dictators they took out like
political Rivals I mean anything drug
lords the whole nine yards like
sometimes crazy there's stories where
these guys would go into a place and
just kill 30 people just to get to one
guy AI right like I mean it's it's nuts
other times they would go in with just
surgical Precision but it was nuts how
capable these guys were but this is the
team not not directly but this is a team
that would eventually go on to become
part of weapons plus right Weapon X the
group that had adamantium bonded to them
or at least the healing factor of
Wolverine granted to them now Jackson
and cruel they were not part of the the
team for weapons plus that was oh my God
that was Silver Fox and someone else I
don't think it was Kestrel or Mastodon
maybe it was I can't remember off top my
head it's been 20 years since I read
those Comics guys bear with me here I
may have forgotten a little bit but the
thing about this is that this team is
ridiculously dangerous but once they get
in there right once they get to their
location in South America being sent on
this Mission the kind of monologue we
get is he says when you've lived as long
and as hard as I have memories get
broken and scrambled there are times I
can can remember as clear as a picture
there are other times that feel like I'm
looking at myself through the wrong end
of a telescope and there are other times
that are gone all together and he says
thanks to Professor Thornton after so
many mind wipes after so much training
that honed my nerves to a Razor's Edge I
was less a mutant and more of an Arsenal
back then and he says our Intel told us
a gorilla force was planning a coup a
former General was storing weapons and
rallying support from a jungle
stronghold we were supposed to make sure
he never came into Power everything was
sleepy and quiet at dawn once we took
out the century it would be easy
pickings right they get into this place
and they find everybody's been skimmed
right so it's like a throwback to the
original Predator from Arnold
Schwarzenegger which is awesome right
and he says or so we thought something
triggered deep inside my brain a lost
memory of a monster in the woods of a
first and final hunt I might have
forgotten about the Predator but he had
not forgotten about me and this time he
brought reinforcements so unlike their
first encounter whereas Wolverine
fighting one now he's fighting four with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end we will see you guys in a
month for part two I know it's gonna
suck to have to wait and I will catch
you all later peace